they can't hide this much longer they
can't hide his ineptitude they can't
hide the bad ratings they can't hide the
fact that he can't read the teleprompter
and that when he
does go off teleprompter that it's a
muddled mess they can't hide it much
longer
here on nbc is politico's betsy woodruff
swann talking about this problem that
they have related to hiding this guy
the staff seems overly protective
yeah there's no question and that's part
of the reason he's out front so little
he's done such a tiny number of recent
interviews and now of course in this ap
interview the message that he's sending
that people are highlighting is he's
recognizing that there's a lot of pain
and suffering in this country giving
people a little jimmy carter flashback
you know a word he never actually said
but malays his infamous malaysia's
speech and that's something that senior
white house staff are acutely aware of
once the mainstream media starts
relating this thing to jimmy carter and
the malaise then it's like oh we would
rather
have anybody and jimmy carter very
famously gave a speech around 1980 or so
about this malaise this depression that
everyone knew they were in and gas
prices were sky high and everything else
and then you know who came in this
ronald reagan guy and we had a pretty
damn good eight years in america